[Music]  gone through divorce it's may be using  thing especially with kids come on you  have a child you would see what kind of  devastation it would be is something  what happened to you and Vincent I just  need to create some boundaries what are  the things that that turn you off Oh  everything is a blur and there's nothing  that separates anything it's not like  this is the marriage it's just the you  know parental side of it this is the  work side of it this is the fun side of  it it's everything is Buffett it can't  be your husband your man is your best  friend your baby daddy and all like that  it's just  oh my god I'm up on to you every day  every day like doctor like I love him to  drive to see his face - I was a day I  come on if I go off and go to work and  come back home and he's not there my day  is better when I get home  [Music]  you